but I don't do things from one goal
really was not so much to make a lot of
money
I never chase money chase the vision not
the money which is not money Center
money has never been our goal money
money
don't chase money yeah I'm not
interested in the financial coastal want
to continue success but there's no
specific mark our finances do the work
because to be honest with you if I'm
sitting here with you a year from now
two years from now and they like you did
it you're a billionaire i'ma still be
saying it but I got another idea right a
new idea and it's what I think is
representation of a person who's truly
ambitious because ambition isn't a
learned behavior it's a part of your
natural character and you'll always find
something to be passionate about our new
goal or new you see guys sell companies
five six billion dollars and go yeah
okay now what's the next one in your
book the art of the deal you said that
money really isn't that important it's
just a means of keeping score it's
playing the game that excites you I love
the game I like the money and the money
is certainly a method of keeping score
but I don't do things for money I do
things because I enjoy doing that really
sometimes can translate into more money
than you would have made if you went
just after the money our goal was the
gut we started with four employees and
our goal was to get 250 employees and
the goal really was not so much to make
a lot of money I'm I'm on it I wanted to
me a lot of money in those days was I
want to own a house I want to have a
nice car and I wanted to work with
interesting people and do interesting
things and I thought if I could control
my own environment have a small
consulting company an Oracle started out
as a software consulting company we work
for tandem computer if anyone remembers
those guys we work for IBM that we work
for a lot of different tech companies in
Silicon Valley doing contract
programming fixed-price contract
programming and we did pretty well
actually and again the idea was just to
have a small software contract software
company a budget you know we thought
were a hotshot programmers and we
thought we could make a decent living
doing just that and quite by accident
we built a product most of the people
that watch this are relatively rich
people right I mean and most of them are
gonna earn a living
they'll eat though live you know they'll
be fine
beyond that there should be something to
do that's useful that's something that
says okay I did something I didn't just
work on the door latch all my life or
something you know what not to say door
latches are bad I mean I'm sure guys
work on their latches and then toss them
but at the end of your life you want to
say did I do something of value or in
the beginning or in the middle you know
if every day you go to work and it's
like office space you know where I you
did yeah do I care does anybody care if
that's what it's gonna be then get paid
less do something useful you're gonna be
way better off and and chasing money I
never chase money you know people ask me
well when did you decide to give it away
I never in the problem is I never was
interested in having a toys right but
it's one of those if you're trying don't
try it happens it's in a cool factor you
said it sort of when I was young anyway
if you're trying to be cool you weren't
okay it's so it's it's sort of if you do
that that which is has value you're much
better off the great companies had a
vision that had a higher purpose beyond
just money or profits or being number
one in a market and kind of the irony
there is that by not making profits the
number one priority of the company or
the higher purpose of the company it
actually enabled these companies to make
generate more profits in the long term
so sometimes when I speak at
entrepreneur conferences I get asked
what's a good market to get into where I
can make a lot of money and my response
is amiss instead of thinking about where
you can make a lot of money think about
what are you so passionate about doing
that you'd be happy doing it for 10
years and even if you never made a dime
and that's what you should be doing and
kind of the ironic thing is the money
will actually follow so you know we've
all heard of Craigslist he didn't set
out to make money he was passionate
about the community and now it's one of
the top trafficked websites on the
internet so I like to say chase the
vision not the money there was a movie
that came out a I think a couple years
ago I called notorious I think it only
lasted a week in the movie theater but
but I saw it and I in it
biggie smalls also known as notorious
b.i.g is well Puff Daddy says to biggie
smalls don't chase the paper chase the
dream I just want an excuse to put this
picture up here anyways so if you're an
entrepreneur say think about what would
you be so passionate about doing that
you'd be happy doing it for ten years
even if you never made a dime from it
and if you have employees now what's the
larger vision and greater purpose in
their work beyond just money or profits
or being number one in a market
everything that we do in the business
world is focused on making money that's
what indicate indicator that you try to
assess how successful we are in the
business world there's nothing else so
that kind of squeezed out all kinds of
social orientation of human life and
human activity and that's not a tenable
situation and that untenable situation
is created by the structure that we have
said business doesn't have to be always
money center always self centered always
or many times obsessed with money
because human beings is not they are not
always about money human beings is much
bigger than just money making machine we
are not robots we are human beings we
take care of ourselves individually at
the same time we take care of everybody
else we take care of the planet itself
and business world doesn't have that
orientation so at the moment we can do
that we can create a different kind of
business which is not money centered I
don't think it's about money has never
been our goal I never I never knew I was
going to write a book that sold millions
and millions of copies and so I don't
take a salary from the church now but
it's about you know money is simply a
tool to fulfill your destiny but I teach
people you give money away
you help we give millions of dollars in
victory net not never dreamed that we'd
be able to do to be able to bless people
like this so it's never been about you
know how wealthy can we become Airbnb we
created a company not because I wanted
to be some successful entrepreneur and
make a bunch of money if I was going to
do that I would not have started
air-beds
for conferences around the country that
was not going to be a good idea in fact
I had a mentor I told about the idea of
airbend breakfast and he told me I hope
that's not the only idea you're working
on and my mom growing up all she ever
wanted I went to art school she said
just make sure you get a job that has
health insurance and so I created when
we created our bed and breakfast she
said us I guess you never got that job
of health insurance this is what happens
you start having to let strangers in
your homes what motivates you to keep
working as hard as you still are you
know that's an interesting question a
lot of people don't seem to get it it
had it goes back to the time when I
discovered that I was something called
an entrepreneur until I was 32 I thought
I could hold down a job I gave a talk at
Babson College a Business School in
Boston to something called the
entrepreneurial exchange and I asked the
people the
300 kids in the audience and I said how
many of you think you entrepreneurs and
everybody raised the head and then I
asked him I said how many of you were in
the entrepreneur business want to be in
the entrepreneur business for money
nobody's ever guessed how many people
raise their hand too many people to
guess here so I'll tell you one God is
the answer to the question what is the
reason why people want to be
entrepreneurial my answer is the sense
of achievement talk about something it's
not the money
now I'm not gonna send money back the
only sunny we have Botox in Piazza young
you have come cheating on this issue all
of Sue's you Coco CJ sakauchi vulgar
yeah
I am highly cannot some young to some
cockeyed
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
you think about the topic not chasing
money I'd love to know why you started
your business and what your main goal is
for me I've always been driven by impact
so the things that I do that get me
really excited are the things that I can
make a lot of money on it's what can I
do that will have a big impact and touch
a lot of people's lives that's what gets
me really fired up and excited
encouraged for you which one of the
clips had the biggest impact on you and
why do you do things for the money or
what are you motivated by leave it in
the comments below I'll join the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon